on the specific allegation have you ever
used anal beads while playing chess no
God please no no
well you know your curiosity is a bit
concerning you know maybe you're
personally interested but uh I can tell
you no
okay
kind of Interest how do you how do you
disprove that you've used anal beads to
cheat
how could I you know prove disprove a
negative it's like oh no you expect me
but but let's first off discuss the you
know that is not a serious Theory okay
that was something that was taken out of
context and that was never a serious
thing that was something that the media
caught up but that was you know if you
if you look at the the consensus among
chess players the consensus among
experts it is an unequivocal fact that I
have never cheated in an over-the-board
game so I find you know again I'm just
wondering how do you disprove it I mean
were you strip search did they explore
cavities where do we go here
[Music]
well through tournaments there are
security checks where they you know will
do you know various Security checks you
know metal detectors different scanners
um
would that pick up anal beads
[Music]
I don't know Pierce
you should you should invite them on
your show and ask them that it appears
that that's the main topic of your
curiosity appears to be that as opposed
to the fact that you have a 19 year old
champion who defeated a champion who
defeated the whole world of Chess in the
largest cyber bullying case in history
the world of Chess versus Hans Neiman
and he's here to talk about it and he's
still a Victor and instead of becoming
bitter he became better and you want to
ask him about the anal beads something
he never said or never did we don't know
the answer to that question Pierce maybe
you can ask the anal B people have them
on your show and they can explain it to
you better
hahaha
and will you allow yourself to be strip
searched just to rule out any rumors
what bro what are you talking about man
I find that question to be just you know
I can't take you seriously when you ask
those questions Pierce I'm sorry because
you're entertaining uh uh uh honestly an
allegation that should should not even
be taken seriously because it's it's
purely you know for you know for you to
get media attention when this when this
is it's not even a serious thing how
could how can you as a reporter take
that allegation seriously at all well I
understand Elon Musk uh no but you
genuinely believe that no but do you do
you actually believe that that is the
case I don't know could you could you
even I don't know I don't know I know
you're capable of cheating because
you've admitted it I don't know how far
you go
Elon Musk as you know tweeted uh on what
was known as Twitter then is now X
Talent hit to Target no one else can
hear genius hits a Target no one can see
because it's in your butt
what did you feel when you read that
happy
well I was a bit surprised
um you know uh I was surprised uh you
know I I didn't really think much of it
you know I I focused on competing and I
don't let these things affect me and my
goal is to become the best chess player
in the world and and to give back to
chess players all around the world and
uh I think that chess is a beautiful
game that should be spread and that's
why I intend to do a lot more charity
work and give back to the communities
who helped me do you think when you play
Magnus Carlson again you'll kick his
butt for one of a better phrase
you know I'll just let my chest pick for
itself
this is simply a case of of you know
where Bullies Are are you know going
after someone because they threaten
their business interests
of course he's a bully he used his
entire Empire he used his connection to
chess.com he leveraged his you know the
fact that there's a you know a merger
happening and he got all these people to
attack me and it was it's a bully it's a
simple thing